the PlayStation Vita is dead long live
the Vita because as you know Vita means
life and you can never kill rumors of a
PlayStation handheld there is a bunch of
talk out there yet again that
PlayStation is working on yet another
handheld console here's what you need to
know discussions around this device
started soon after the reveal from Asus
and its Rog Ally handheld a post on the
gaming leaks and rumors subreddit popped
up from someone that claims to have
played around with a unit as well as
spoken to people at Asus the details
which should be taken with a massive
grain of salt claim that the handheld
with 512 gigabytes of storage is aiming
to hit the price point of the most
expensive steam deck at 649 with a
second one terabyte model at 900
supposedly launching in October of this
year considering the impressive
performance we've seen from asus's
device from the few YouTubers that have
officially gone Hands-On with it if it
can hit that price point that would give
the steam deck some actual confidence
petition the company is supposedly also
partnering with Microsoft on promoting
the handheld as it runs on Windows and
hence could run Game Pass games natively
something the steam deck can't do unless
you install Windows on it which is not
how the device comes out of the box
instead running its Linux based Steam OS
according to the post the reason Asus is
partnering with Microsoft is not only
because of Game Pass but because the
company is aware the PlayStation is
working on its own handheld console as
well once these potential leaks were
posted word started circulating online
specifically around the potential of yet
another portable PlayStation at this
point Jeff Grubb of Gamespot sister site
Giant Bomb tweeted quote I see the
reports about a potential Vita 2 and I
would definitely scope down those
expectations I've only ever heard about
a cloud streaming handheld then
following that tweet inside a gaming put
out a full report on what it knows about
the situation according to the site
PlayStation's upcoming handheld is
codenamed Q light and does indeed not
run games natively instead exclusively
streaming them over the Internet like
logitech's gcloud product however
curiously the report claims that this
isn't happening via games playing on
Sony's remote servers but instead simply
utilizes the PlayStation 5's built-in
Remote Play functionality and allows
players to stream their games to other
devices from their own console inside of
gaming points to the company's recent
Remote Play focused ads that it put out
in recent weeks as the beginning of an
awareness campaign for consumers the
device will supposedly have an 8-inch
1080p 60hz screen with early prototypes
reportedly looking like a screen with
either half of a dual sense controller
on the sides the handheld will
supposedly also sport the same haptic
feedback and adapter triggers of the PS5
controller as well finally inside a
gaming claims that Sony intends to
release the Q light after its rumored
Slimmer PS5 with detachable disk drive
but also before the rumored PS5 Pro that
inside gaming claims is targeting a
holiday 2024 launch I don't know on the
one hand it seems really weird for the
PlayStation to create a handheld that
doesn't even use cloud streaming it just
uses remote play but on the other hand
that seems totally like something Sony
would do I don't know what do you think
about all the rumors of a new
PlayStation Portable can you believe we
may actually get one let me know in the
comments below and we'll see you here
for more Gamespot news
foreign